I can't start the day without my
caffeine fix while I normally fire up
the Keurig or hide down to my local
Starbucks today I'm getting a special
delivery from craft coffee hey good
morning
so why is this better than going to my
local Starbucks for a cup of joe we
source from over 40 states from hundreds
of Roasters around the country the
verdict save you time it's cheaper than
my local Starbucks and it showed up at
my door
time to get spruced up usually it takes
me about half an hour to do my own hair
and makeup but today I'm getting some
help from the glam squad team what do
you think any changes you want to make
or no that's great I love it the verdict
it took about as long as when I do my
own hair and makeup the price point was
a little high but it was convenient they
did it all right in my own home
now Cinderella just needs to choose her
gown my least favorite part of the day
good thing I already picked out a dress
from up the runway Rent the Runway is a
New York based startup that lets people
rent designer dresses at a much lower
price I picked out a few online ended up
choosing this one after I went into
their store and flat iron and tried them
on this one will run me 50 bucks rental
but it was 250 dollars off the rack so
I'd say that's a good deal
so now I'm here at the Rennes in the
East Village about to take a private
cocktail making class
all thanks to gilt City let's go meet
the bartender hi welcome to the res
let's have some drinks let's do it
mmm that's really good the verdict it
didn't save me time because I had to
look for the class it did save me a bit
of money a $70 sticker price is cheaper
than the usual hundred dollars you'd
spend but I wouldn't do this type of
thing every day I'm back home preparing
for a dinner party for a few of my
friends but today I get to skip the
grocery shopping cooking and the
cleaning because I'm here with James
from kitchen surfing what are you gonna
make for me tonight
today cod with cavatelli roasted
fingerling potatoes and side of green
beans with almonds so the kitchen
surfing now it's delicious
but for $25 a head I don't know if this
is right for me for it every day night
I'm entertaining definitely something
that I would consider but for a normal
workday it might be a little bit too
pricy for what I'm usually looking for
cheers Cheers